Chris and Bree congratulations you won
the first season of listen to your heart
how crazy is that to be able to say
we're still processing it getting used
to it yeah it's Roland what is it like
when you hear your names called
by Chris Harrison imagine yourself in a
dream and you are like vibrating from an
earthquake but it's not an earthquake
just voices and then if you just close
your eyes and like Bree and I we hugged
each other might have been four five ten
seconds it felt like 15 minutes and like
we were just like eyes closed just like
hearing like the roar it felt like it
was an experience unlike anything else
[Music]
when I was watching you to sing in that
final performance I swear I got the
chills it was like you were singing your
feelings at each other I could see it in
your eyes what was going through each of
your minds during that final performance
three I'll start with you so the final
performance was absolutely terrifying
because it was a competition and we had
to show communicate our love and also be
good performers and hit the right note
so there's so much going through my head
in that moment I had to remember what
was most important and literally forget
about everybody else otherwise it would
become it would become the wrong thing
you know and so in order to properly
communicate that and express how I truly
felt about him I just had to lock in on
him let me be locked in the eyes were
magnetized what about you were you
nervous excited scared I mean definitely
all of those things I mean I felt like
LeBron James or Michael Jordan's
shooting that last freako like you know
breeze the basket and that's my that we
have eyes on you guys are a beautiful
couple you sing beautifully together
I believe everything I would pay money
to see you guys I mean Taye Diggs said
he would pay money to see you guys yeah
yeah and I hope he does it was just such
a really cute little card at the end
with this photo of you guys that said
you're still together you're still super
happy now you're not physically together
so you aren't Quarantine together
no we wish we were but work at us you
know in different places and then
everything got shut down and we kind of
just stayed where we were but you know
the second it's over we will be together
for sure
Chris how are you feeling in the
relationship right now I feel fantastic
I mean I'm honestly happier than I've
been in my entire life which is just
relief because I'm 30 I'm ready to get
my life started on the right foot
so I mean besides the quarantine
obviously it's what
better to be physically next to breathe
then to be talking to her but at the
same time like I'm just so happy
free what about you I'm doing well um
you know usually my personality I'm not
super great with long-distance
relationships in the past but apparently
when you find the right person it it
isn't challenging and we've had lots of
FaceTime dates we talked multiple times
a day so it's been it's been really
wonderful in a different way
well you're saying you're not great at
long-distance so I'm just gonna ask you
guys why don't you just bite the bullet
and somebody fly somewhere and you start
coordinating together we've almost done
it about a thousand times
trust me yeah yeah we still have money
tied up with American Airlines believe
me we've been there so what do we need
to do with American Airlines to get you
guys together like are you trying to be
together or do they need to send you
some money what's going on here we are
absolutely trying to be together and I
think the thing is is you know all of
this took us by surprise and we were
expecting to be together sooner or to
have things opened up sooner I have a
compromised immune system and so
traveling is the biggest issue but we've
you know we're figuring it out I'm dying
quite frankly dying why cuz you like
need him to hold you what he is I am a
very you know I'm a very I don't I don't
want to say physical person because it
kind of you know contradicts what we
were just spoke about earlier but
everything aside from that like yes I
need to be held I need to be able to
hold your hand and kiss you and
everything and it it just you need
physical touch in a relationship so how
is your relationship grown even since
filming ended what's so interesting
about our relationship it's unlike any
other romantic relationship we've been
in we're friends were music partners
were business partners and then we're
also romantic partners so we've been
working and building on each one of
those levels three I do gotta ask you
you had talked about getting your heart
kind of crushed in this engagement that
you had before I was engaged I care
here we go I texted and I was like I am
dying like I have the dress and he
literally called me like that second and
he was like don't buy it where do you
fall on a potential engagement have you
guys talked about that we're kind of
just taking it day by day especially
with you know the current climate but my
past relationships have taught me you
know it's easy to just put up your walls
and be like I'm never doing this again
I'm never open you know myself again but
it's not fair to you know the next
person that you meet and you're never
going to get anywhere I've learned I'm
strong enough to get through it so cross
my fingers with this one does that mean
you've talked about marriage Chris I
mean it's definitely been a topic of
discussion but you know I'm not trying
to get married tomorrow and I know brie
isn't either and you're trying to get
married next month you know but in the
future for sure 3 when the fantasy
suites came up we see you pull back a
little bit I definitely want to take
things slow
I'm crazy what happened there because I
thought you were in love so yeah it
wasn't as much about the emotional
connection because my feelings with
Chris were established from day one it
wasn't that I was questioning it it's
just that physical intimacy is I'm going
to take very serious and Chris does as
well so luckily we had a mutual
agreement on that I'm gonna ask you a
question that's personal but this is a
bachelor show has there been an
opportunity since filming end I mean
wait yeah we've we've been able to be
close to each other but there's nothing
you know going down like that you know I
mean I know that you know what's let's
mess me up in the past is like really
just being physically intimate with
anybody and it messes up with all the
emotions like Bruce is saying and we
know how much we care about each other
and we know where we want to go and so
we want to give ourselves a best shot
and if that means just like you know
taking it slow and hanging out then girl
that's all I'm gonna do you guys have
not been intimate yet no we haven't had
sex and it's not something that we're
trying to do you know
so are you guys just planning to wait
till engagement or marriage and that's
just kind of where you're both at yeah
great cool
more car to you that's great and I think
that this love deserves better than a
proposal in quarantine so tell him I
want to talk about the finale kind of
gave me goosebumps when they flash back
in the finale and and they look back at
your relationship and they literally
have on camera the moment you met did
you each know this person is really
special it took two days you know the
first day there was a lot going on when
meeting you're trying to meet everyone
in the mansion and then night - it was
it was him from then on out ya know it's
really it I mean night - I had my girls
lined up of who I'm gonna shoot my shot
at and three at that time was my first
choice I did a shooting my shot second
and then once I met her I'm like alright
well I don't need to meet anybody else
and then Bri you went ahead and said I
love you on stage in front of an
audience I just hugged him you know
after and I said I love you but you
didn't hear and I haven't told you that
yet next to our dad Chris Harrison
what's going through your minds that
made you do that it just came out and
that's how I knew I meant it because I
hadn't even thought about it
you know it just came out and that's
what love is it's natural it's real and
when you're comfortable that's when you
take those next steps with that person
and it just happened to me on stage do
you guys ever think to yourself or
second-guess like wait do we really
connect to Orange or do we just love
performing together what's driving it
more did you have those questions I
really did it no absolutely no great it
was kind of the opposite for me like we
I have been performing for a really long
time but
I still get very nervous and so the fact
that I was able to get up there with
Chris and fight those nerves and do it
together it just second stone our
foundation even more what is the reality
of the tour what's the status the
reality is that there's a big pause
button on it right now
you know base with Corona but we are
still planning on going on tour in
connecting with our fans and sharing our
music the way that we want to and we're
not gonna let coronavirus get us down
and you know we're gonna look forward to
you know putting up some online concerts
and stuff like that so yeah did you guys
go ahead and just make a whole album
though in all this like tell me about
that somehow do we made an album we have
five originals and five covers on the
album the five cover songs we sing on
the show in two months in different
states recorded in different studios
writing everything through FaceTime like
it it was insane I was able to come to
LA for two weekends before the lockdown
happened and then the rest was you know
finished through FaceTime and it was
just insane but we did it how are you
guys gonna feel though about being able
to kind of like be public with things
and tell people yeah we're still
together and we're super happy I mean
for me I'm you know a relatively private
person but I live my life in the public
eye and it's been very weird for months
to not tell people what is going on you
know so in short it's just gonna be an
absolute relief to be like yo I got a
girlfriend
her name is Brie and she's sick and you
know we're fantastic together it feels
great yeah and to go off of that um I
was telling Chris like it's it was
really weird
to have to hide it for so long but in a
way I was really grateful because again
we had to rely on each other we didn't
have the opinions of others it was just
us we had every opportunity to break up
and not be together there but instead it
got way stronger than ever before
[Music]